hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
alchum of york at the very beginning of
his treatise on virtues and vices which
is addressed to count guy
in the first five chapters talks about
wisdom and then what are traditionally
called the theological virtues of faith
hope and charity and then talks about
zeal in reading reading the scriptures
and this is very interesting and i think
significative
because he is he's talking to count guy
who he says is very busy with you know
martial warlike activities guy is not
a monk as alkawin is
and alchemin is
centering him around these matters that
are you could say theological and
intellectual at the very beginning
instead of saying ah be courageous you
know be just which will come up later on
he's saying these are going to
need to be discussed first and so the
very
first thing that he begins with is in
fact wisdom and he says the first thing
of all
that should be sought by a person is
what true
and the latin word there is vera so it's
not just any sort of
pretended wisdom or knowledge but true
knowledge and true wisdom skientia and
sapientia
so you know scientia this is the word
that we actually get science from
this means really knowing something and
then sapientia goes beyond
just knowing and has to do
with
how we regulate our lives and all of
that and notice what he also does he
contrasts this to the wisdom of the
world which is foolishness before god
and he quotes paul's letter to first
corinthians
so there's a contrast here that's being
made between
other rival
claimants to wisdom what is genuine
wisdom and what is genuine knowledge
according to elko and he tells us that
true knowledge is to withdraw from the
servitude of the devil so it's it's
arranged in this christian narrative
framework and what is the servitude of
the devil it doesn't mean actually like
saying oh satan i worship and serve you
it just means sinning right he says
these are sins and perfect wisdom
is to worship god according to the truth
of he's his mandates in these two things
uh blessed life is acquired and harry
says something really interesting so now
we see that that wisdom and knowledge is
already centered in a practical and not
merely theoretical way
he tells us
invoking this passage from the psalms
turn away from evil and do good
both of these sides are important it's
not just enough to like turn away from
evil quit doing bad things you gotta
actually do good things you gotta move
over to the other side and he also tells
us that um
it's you know we
you don't suffice to do good things
unless you also don't commit bad things
right you move away from the bad and you
know if we look at ourselves carefully
i'm sure we can all find some bad things
that we probably should move away from
so that's how he frames wisdom in a very
practically oriented sense which will
connect later on with the four cardinal
virtues when he talks about prudence or
practical wisdom prudencia
then in the next three chapters and a
little bit out of order we're going to
take these on the traditional faith hope
and charity rather than in the order
that alkowin does them because
for him
he talks about faith first then he talks
about charity then he talks about hope
but
let's let's look at them in the
traditional order so faith right
what is faith it's got a double sense
here in this he says
this knowledge of the godhead and
knowledge of the truth is to be learned
through the catholic faith right so what
it is that christianity
mediated through the church teaches
about it so
that's connecting faith to wisdom but
then he also talks about
faith in the sense that we typically
think about it belief having a
commitment to things
and he says um
you know he is blessed who lives well by
believing rightly and keeps the right
faith by by living well
now this is going to lead us into
something that
christians very often disagree about but
was very important for early to medieval
christians and continues to be important
for a number of others and you notice
that he is going to
invoke
the letter from james right and james
says
what would it profit my brothers if
someone should say he has faith but does
not do
works will his faith be able to save him
faith without works is dead and so this
is a very important conception of faith
faith
is integrally connected with
doing something and you see this running
throughout many
christian authors right they pick up on
this and they say faith is useless
without good works but good works profit
nothing without right faith so there's a
dialectical or complementary
relationship between what you believe
and what you actually do and in a way
you could say well you can claim you
believe something but if you're not
actually doing something that
corresponds to it you don't really
believe in it or it's dead faith as they
talk about it and he has a very
interesting comparison here just as a
body without spirit is dead so faith
without works
is dead
what's the actual correspondent there is
it that faith is like the spirit of the
works
the way that alcohol has this set up
maybe not actually maybe the faith is
the body and the works are the spirit
and then he passes on very quickly to
discuss charity but let's talk about
what he says about hope
so he tells us
the excellent doctor of the gentiles
that's uh you know paul
set out three things necessary to our
soul saying hope faith charity these are
three but greatest from these is charity
and so he says no one however much he's
forced to weigh the enormity of his sins
ought to despair about the goodness of
divine piety right and this is where
hope is going to come in
hope is not just well i hope i get a
sandwich when i get home or you know i
hope my sports team wins or something
like that
hope can also be this taking account of
oh man i'm a miserable sinner but i can
hope
in what divine mercy or compassion
misericordia right i can hope that i'm
going to be judged not according to my
merits but according to
mercy and made into
a good person right and so he says
[Music]
we ought to neither sin perseveringly
because of hope of mercy right we
shouldn't like do sins and say well god
will take care of it
nor since god justly punishes sins ought
we despair of mercy but turning
with both dangers avoided turn aside
from bad
and expect mercy from the piety of god
similarly in difficulties of tribulation
we should run with hope to the solace of
supernal piety since all hope and
salvation consists in him alone so hope
has a double sense for the christian
hope in divine mercy and hope that we'll
make it through these tribulations to a
greater
good
what about charity the section on
charities a bit longer and he has a lot
of interesting things to say
about this
he begins by saying
charity obtains first place in the
precepts of god precepts are commands
you know do this do that
without charity's perfection
he says nothing else can please god so
neither martyrdom nor contempt of the
world nor largess of alms giving a lot
of people things without charity or
without love is another way of
translating karitas right
and
then he brings up the two
great commandments
the lord himself asked by a scribe what
was his greatest mandate replied
love the lord with god the lord your god
with all your heart with all your soul
with all your mind and then he said the
symbol the second is similar to this
love your neighbor as yourself in these
two mandates hang all the law and the
prophet so
charity can be summed up in this love of
god and love of neighbor
and elkin says something really
interesting here about the the love of
god part
there's a great clarification he says
when he says with all your heart
all your soul all your mind
what is this really translating into he
arranges this in terms of the human
faculties
and he says that god is to be loved with
all your intellect intellectual right so
or understanding you're your cognitive
faculties
with all your will volontas uh you know
this faculty of choosing of committing
ourselves which allows us to to work
upon our our own characters and you know
eliminate vices and from the whole
memory why why memory well you know
within uh the the framework of medieval
thought memory is indeed quite important
you could say memory is what we carry
around with us all the time it's this
great to use the classic metaphor
thesaurus or storehouse or treasure
house right so we're supposed to
adopt those right but then what about
command what about the the neighbor
and here he says something really quite
striking now remember that alcuin is
writing at a time when christianity is
not uh universal in europe as a matter
of fact he is part of the carolingenian
renaissance meaning that charlemagne is
going to bring alkuhin to teach uh
outside of york in in his capital
and charlemagne is having campaigns not
just against you know muslims but
against uh pre-christian pagans in
europe and notice what alcuin says about
charity towards the neighbor he doesn't
say it means charity towards everybody
everybody is your neighbor
what does he actually say
here
every christian is rightly said to be
his neighbor
why because we're all sanctified in the
baptism of the son of god so we're
spiritually brothers
in perfect charity and
you could say well that's very
exclusionary i mean i think alcuin is
also saying though it's hard enough just
to love your own fellow co-religionists
with whom you have this in common try to
do that first right
and that is quite an
interesting matter to to explore
then he's going to talk about something
else that i think figures in here very
importantly and actually brings this
together something very practical that
has to do with how one orients one's
life
in chapter five he talks about zeal of
reading
lexionis studio now this word zeal means
something like enthusiasm
a commitment to do something over and
over again valuing prioritizing
something so
now reading what reading books reading
anything you know getting onto blog
posts and reading those no sacred
scripture
and why well this this ties in again
with you know a lot of monastic uh
attitudes and practices
so
there's a number of things that al kuhn
is going to say here that are really
quite important he says a reading of the
holy scriptures is the knowledge of
divine blessedness so if you want wisdom
and you want to practice these
virtues you need to actually engage
with
holy scripture
and and why a little bit later on he
says that
the blind person offends more often than
the seeing the one not knowing the law
of god
sins ignorantly more often than the one
who knows just as a blind person without
a leader walks the right way with
difficulty so a person without a teacher
so the scriptures can be in effect a
teacher
why well they do several things one is
they act as he says a kind of mirror
right speculum right it's in speculo we
can look at ourselves
in the mirror a person can consider
themself
what he might be or to what he might aim
right
and then there's another factor that
figures in with this reading purifies
the soul produces fear of hell
stimulates the heart of the reader to
eternal joys he wants to be with god
always
frequently
wants to pray and read why
when we pray he says
we actually talk with god
and he uses these these two terms
loqui mirror right we speak and loquitur
he speaks
how does that work well when we pray we
are speaking with god
when we read god is speaking with us
through the intermediary of the
scriptures and there's this very you
know complex
uh guided way of reading the scriptures
that the you know monastic authors will
talk about elsewhere and he's sort of
assuming that
he says that the
reading of the holy scriptures also
confers a twin gift what is the twin
gift well it ties in with our our mind
our intellect and our heart or our
will
it educates the understanding of the
mind intellectual mentis right
and it also leads a person to the love
amor in this case but charity is what's
going on there of god abstracted from
the
vanities of the world so
through engaging in this process of
scripture reading we are placed into
a deeper relation with the
the you know you could say the the great
thing god that all the scriptures are
supposed to be
centered upon so these are some very
interesting things to stress in these
first five chapters
of the on virtues and vices writing not
to fellow monks but writing to a
military man who is looking for some
guidance
you